parlate di ragazzi e benvenuti sì ma
questo nuovo video di minecraft parkour
ragazzi era un anno di più due anni e da
quando sono nato che lo faccio più magra
farti con il buon amico pietre cia
michela è un sacchismo di tempo bello
che non facciamo un video insieme su
michael mi voleva iniziare da due giorni
non facciamo video insieme però doveva
studente fare manca parkour perché
quando abbiamo iniziato da quando ci
siamo detti di iniziano a fare video
insieme avete tab e mike apertura è la è
la prima cosa non può non può non
esserci mai cras parkour che veramente
incredibile anzi la il fiore
all'occhiello dei nostri video quindi
giochiamo mai cup alcun questo si chiama
parkour strikes se non sbaglio perché
che ne so io non lo so l'inverno bravo
dice libico la partenza questa nuova
serie di cosi non è vero che hai fatto
sarà una serie che dovrà veramente un
sacco di tempo
il problema è una cosa ma tutti e di là
e la velocità la tieni sempre attiva
perché il fondo salto sino ad ora la
tengo attiva perché volevo farti cadere
ma quanto pare ci riesce benissimo ma i
fatti ma perchè non non capisco ma tu mi
hai fatta arrivare lassù
ok ci sono ma vuoi smettere che siamo
all'inizio del video mannaggia allora
questa è un po di vino è fortissimo una
donna che ha velocità dell'amica pietre
mamma mia
bravissimi number blu e un livello sia
tutta la striscia di c è si guarda io so
che fare 45 sono sei amiche di gabbo
come fare goodbye salta barca vedete
anche lei comunque abbiamo preso lo
sapeva bene abbiamo fatto la via via si
è riuscito però di perdersi devi
schiacciare dalla stanza di cemento
carlo mamma mia mamma faceva bene amiche
facile
questa dovrebbe essere falsi esatto di
sé quello che cazzo è questo
questo qua scusa io passare a nostri
come se fossimo passare ma dai è piccolo
spoiler
fare ma guarda mamma mia
alla fine devi fare una roba un po no 17
no però bisognerà è stata la 17 ma è
perché sono 14 blocchi da saltare sei lo
spintonava spinto a non è vero non ce
l'ho ce l'ho li facciamo come mai il
salto a 732 uno no a prima prima prima
prima di prima ok vogliano prima di
cosiddetta l'ultima volta validi e vado
a mercato opposto è la mano gravissimo
ciao amica prossima per capire la prova
che dai secoli dai tommy calabrese e
invece e invece a ok e lo slime l'avevo
visto bravi fori guarda prima ne vado
vado io vada al momento bellissimo
va bene e mobili mi sembra che sembrava
finita realtà non lo è per niente
cacchio no ma ragazzi impossibile st
livello come fatto andava su ok
vai ok rissi monado di randy queen o
testa a posto
giro sopra no è l'amico è caduto come
hai fatto e basta
aspettami ci ha detto ascoltato livello
va bene io no aspetta chi slater allora
lincoln odore di colors tyson fortissimo
chiamano i colori ma non è tutto colore
tutto bianco e nero che colors vogliamo
visti si colori questo poteva essere
caduto mi sa che hanno sbagliato a
scrivere perché gli umori non è proprio
il modo giusto
infatti noi non andiamo vera dice
moriano è opposto il mouse
certamente non già difficilissimo per
favore
ok non è così difficile ma mai veramente
easy mamma mia che giocata ragazzi
pazzesco siamo sicuri che deriva ma se
kadiri quoti poi di ripartire io non
l'ho trovato
secondo me sì visto che non c'è nessun
blocco che copre quindi si fantastico
quindi rischiamo anche di ripartire dice
non lo fare perché effettivamente se
vogliamo tenere
[Musica]
mi che io ho già cominciò del report
contro il mio non ti preoccupare amiche
ma c'è un diamante qui poi c'è il
diamante che una casa una cesta nascosta
questo toro ci sono dei segreti da
trovare in giro si si si sa è ma io mi
stavo concentrando per gli altri due
arrivi il perfetto
guardando questi sono color sono quelli
che prima erano quelli che mi
rappresentavano a mannaggia sono cascato
papa papa no onore a livello con il
ghiaccio lo stesso caduto proprio aiuto
come faccia questa roba non è che
aspetta il gala il giallo sul grande
successo su giallo mannaia e bellissimo
suo livello che ha molto colorato perché
stiamo molto bene ma mano a che livello
va avanti chi sono sempre più colori e
togli c'è spazio per entrambi tranquillo
bravissimo grazie e maemo no vabbè no
dai
no no no no non certo il caso le prime
tranche siamo sul finale dai colors
l'abbiamo fatto quasi quasi è una volta
fuori una volta sola una volta sola
di nuovo da sola in una porta sola siamo
così così tattico proprio oggi al
trionfo purissima e di riaccorciare
aiuto ma non posso avere dolori saltare
esaltare o non è ma dove di saltare di
saltare aspettare di fare un home inc no
io cado 3d lo più caro ma guarda lì
bravo il pulsante amiche e qua qua qua
ma avevamo visto del deserto è vero pure
che comunque non male veramente normale
ricordiamo centro e il diamante perché
abbiamo stracciato non l'abbiamo trovato
nei due fine il 19 non sappiamo neanche
il cantiere secondo me era qua tipo di
inizi e può essere sai perché non a caso
ho visto il diamante detto che cavolo
accusa sarò banca chi non era male
infatti corre molto valenti sapevo
dov'ero
andiamo avanti da amy che voi fate
andare lo stop la scusa devi esatto
vai avanti in avanti hanno fatto
bravissimo su un mezzo su uno e mezzo
nice nice pc se hai fatto poi primo ok
madonna no no nemmeno voglio godermela
chi male ma come i fan ma non lo sai
anche tu come hai falso mai però non lo
sai neanche tu come ci sei riuscita
parola come non lo so neanche io
effettivamente è vero è vero come
cacchio fai questo veramente ragazzi
queste modifiche no non ci credo non ci
posso credere ma con chiara 20 me lo
stai dicendo ciao mikè slater ce l'ho
fatta a michele fatto e cioè fatta se li
vai proci ok ok borghese vedere se
dovevo concentrarmi
no ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta no non è
vero
gli scavi hanno fatto ragazzi bravi che
non ti tocco sono bravo grazie del
nostro che ci hai pensato ho una paura
[ __ ] bacino ai tiri di commandeur te
lo dico monti ho trovato a perfetto a
posto ha trovato evola ma questo così ok
c'è un buco si va beh quando di fare un
mega jia salto quindi questa è una torre
da scalare e il portoghese parte
malissimo è veramente fatto della vita
perché tutto guarda e non passa
tagliavia quattro non sono uscito una
volta che è perfetto ciò fatta
ok no ma è tutto così no perché è una
ragazza speciale sono all'interno ma
come tu te la do io dove s'è spenta
spiega sul bloccarlo che ne so amiche ha
quasi qualcosa ma come c'è qualcosa di
iphone è ok vai da fuori e poi oddio
calma mamma mia ragazzi c'è la moretta e
adesso la facciamo da guarda qua e poi
tornare ancora questo secondo me guarda
o no lo devo a scalare anche questo non
lo so ragazzi io faccio la cavia io
faccio la cavia è prova capita tanto a
voi riformi tutto cavia ti vai amico
vado se possibile mai per favore che non
posso stare così in ansia
grazie difficilissimo capace novice ha
fatto il nuovo brano mi si è aperto il
menu in aria ma perché ok
buongiorno
ok che ci manca solo che il casco di
nuovo ma ce la fai e è facile come fatto
così ed è facilissimo come salto
riaguardo in un superamento è tentato
anche di toccarmi finora io questa
persona deve essere radiata no dal
pianeta ci veramente non potevo rifarmi
tutto da zero può sapere ragazzi era
veramente ciao mikè alla prossima no no
no no ero quasi gianna ha visto cadere
l'ha mai vista cadere ferries ragazzo
non ci arrivo cioè non sono detto ok ok
ok fermi fermenti che lo so come ho
fatto devo andare dentro o fuori
è una domanda stupida perché detto
poteva arrivarci anche la da sotto
quindi salgo ok amiche sono così di cosa
fare qualche addio mamma mia mamma mia e
adesso che ho capito ok calciano ok le
scuole per four ragazzi è stato
difficilissimo ma veramente il nostro
amico pietro tanto amato ci si fa a
livello io concludo qua e ci vediamo al
prossimo bisogno di minecraft sua mamma
aspettami potrebbero servire di mark
fergus raibow che effettivamente saremmo
un qualcosa di concreto c'è una perfetta
se lo continuerò io sono la negazione ha
visto il video iscritti al canale
lasciato un bel mi piace argomento
questo ragazzo era giriamo alla
passionalità bella ragazza
[Musica]